[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as d'information
locale préparé par les équipes de tv 78
et nous sommes le lundi 8 novembre voici
les titres de cette édition
autorités territoire et travail jeudi
xavier bertrand s'est rendu à saint cyr
l'école pour présenter ses idées une
campagne dans le cadre du congrès les
républicains à venir à début décembre
réservé aux adhérents il permettra de
choisir un candidat unique pour les
élections présidentielles de 2022
les radios libres fêtent leurs 40
bougies cette année la date du 9
novembre 1980 marquent la libéralisation
des ondes avant ça allait radio décédé
jamais aimé tes deux façons illégales
les exemples d'anciennes radio
yvelinoise dans ce journal avec radio
vexin val de seine et radio de vieille
église et puis cette semaine c'est le
retour au du dossier de la rédaction
consacré à la hausse des prix aux
oubliés des aides ou encore aux
associations qui s'inquiète est longue
ce soir sur le covoiturage une pratique
prisé depuis la hausse des prix les
centres
[Musique]
moins de trains le week end rallongement
du temps de parcours la ville de saint
cyr l'école interpellée elle la sncf et
ile-de-france mobilité pour un retour
aux anciens horaires sur la ligne l du
transilien le reportage de mathilde fuku
depuis le 22 août la sncf a mis en place
de nouveaux horaires sur la ligne
reliant mantes-la-jolie à paris
montparnasse ou encore rambouillet des
modifications contestée par la ville de
saint cyr l'école j'ai aussi un terrain
était interpellé par des gens qui
s'étonnait de ne pas retrouver alors
qu'il retournait le travail en
présentiel le train qu'ils avaient
l'habitude de prendre est donc très
clairement on a un enjeu parce qu'on a
des parents qui déposent leurs enfants à
l'école ou à la crèche
et qui prennent un train dans le quart
d'heure qui suit pour aller à l'heure au
travail là aujourd'hui on leur dit que
ce train ne circule plus et qu'il faut
partir à un quart d'heure plus tard ou
un quart d'heure plus tôt
le temps de parcours des yvelinois sur
la ligne n s'est allongée de quatre
minutes provoquant des soucis au niveau
de leur correspondance avec d'autres
trains ou bus à chaque fin d'un repas on
ne respecte pas sa correspondance et
puis on aimerait bien que les aides
avant qu'enfin nous reviennent pour
l'élu au transport et à la circulation
un retour aux anciens horaires est
nécessaire dès ce 12 décembre ce qu'on
attend à saint cyr l'école c'est que
dell changement de service donc le 12
décembre prochain on revienne à minima à
la fréquence qu'on connaissait sur l
union n avant qu vide c'est-à-dire un
train tous les quarts d'heure toute la
semaine donc un train par demi-heure sur
les axes et qu'on revienne aux heures de
pointe au schéma de desserte qu'on avait
avant c'est à dire d'être un semis
direct entre sèvres et paris
montparnasse pour les branches de
plaisir grignon et mantes la jolie et
semis direct entre viroflay paris
montparnasse pour les branches de
rambouillet pour permettre aux gens de
ne pas avoir un allongement du temps de
parcours qui est très préjudiciable à la
qualité de vie la ville de saint cyr
l'école espère ainsi pouvoir compter sur
l'appui des autres commune yvelinoise
desservi par la ligne n
le but ce job d'insertion continue sa
tournée dans les yvelines une unité
mobile pour toucher les demandeurs
d'emploi isoler les accompagner dans
leur recherche leur reconversion mais
aussi aider les entreprises à recruter
un projet en partenariat entre le
département lagence interdépartemental
de l'insertion activity pôle emploi et
les missions locales
aujourd'hui le bus jobs insertion était
à retrouver à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines
demain mardi 9 novembre il sera à
mantes-la-ville mercredi 10 novembre aux
mureaux et puis à la queue-lez-yvelines
le vendredi à 12 novembre le bus est
accessible gratuitement et sans rendez
vous
ils sont cinq à faire campagne pour
devenir la tête du parti les
républicains un congrès se tiendra en
ligne du 1er au 4 décembre prochain pour
déterminer le candidat du parti qui se
présentera aux élections présidentielles
de 2022 c'est dans ce cadre que xavier
bertrand s'est rendu au théâtre gérard
philipe de saint cyr l'école ce jeudi 4
novembre pour présenter ses idées lors
d'une réunion publique un reportage avec
ses mines charles
l'autorité le territoire et le travail
voici les trois grands thèmes du
programme de xavier bertrand candidat
pour représenter le parti les
républicains aux élections
présidentielles il s'est rendu au
théâtre gérard philipe de saint cyr
l'école ce jeudi 4 novembre
objectif présenter son projet et
échanger avec les militants mettre fin à
l'impunité les peines minimales
obligatoires quand on s'en prend
physiquement un policier quand on s'en
prend à un les pompiers quand on s'en
prend à un maire
et puis sur le pouvoir d'achat la prime
au travail que quelqu'un qui travaille à
temps complet ne reçoivent pas moins de
1500 euros quelle que soit sa situation
de famille pour récompenser le travail
l'injustice aujourd'hui en france elle
frappe avant tout ceux qui travaillent
et ça c'est pas normal je vais mettre un
terme un congrès les républicains pour
se ranger derrière un représentant
unique aux élections présidentielles ils
sont cinq candidats à se disputer la
place et xavier bertrand valérie
pécresse michèle bernier eric ciotti et
philippe juvin chacun pourra venir
s'exprimer dans les yvelines c'est pas
une primaire c'est un vrai congrès c'est
à dire c'est une course avec un premier
un deuxième un troisième à quatrième
donc le premier j'espère celui qui celui
ou celle qui sortira aura les meilleures
propositions et et on se rangera
derrière lui ou derrière elle pour pour
cette campagne et et gagner parce qu'on
a une vraie chance de gagner une
centaine de personnes a participé à la
réunion publique pour les militants pas
facile de choisir beaucoup sont indécis
les attendent les propositions des
candidats je pense qu a pas beaucoup de
gens qui sont très décidée ce qui est
intéressant au contraire c'est que ça
permet justement
que les gens se posent vraiment réfléchi
écoutez tous des différents débats pour
que je puisse le 4 décembre décider quel
sera le candidat le
le plus intéressant et qui sera apte de
de se présenter à la présidentielle
seuls les adhérents l air pourront
participer au congrès il se déroulera en
ligne du 1er au 4 décembre prochain
une rencontre qui s'est déroulée en
présence de pierre bédier président du
département et de la fédération et les
républicains aient des yvelines
[Musique]
il y à 40 ans le 9 novembre 1981
françois mitterrand a décidé de
libéraliser lé radio soumises auparavant
à un monopole de l'état de nombreuses
radios apparaissait alors au grand jour
c'est le cas dans les yvelines de la rbs
gratuit aux vexin val de seine qui sort
alors de la clandestinité la radio situé
aux mureaux existe depuis 42 ans le
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et mathilde francou
18 juin 1979 date de la première
émission pirates enregistré par rbs deux
ans plus tard la radio du vexin et du
val de seine se voit attribuer une
fréquence lors de la libéralisation des
ondes elle est aujourd'hui l'une des
plus vieilles radios de france ça pue la
radio de france la plus belle radio
associative de france qui à l'époque
était pirates en 79 et en 1980 lorsque
le président mitterrand a libéré les
radios nous sommes devenus donc voilà
officiel et puis bien jusqu'à maintenant
en 2021 nous sommes toujours là sur la
bande fm 96.2 fm je suis dépit la
création de la radio depuis 1979 avant
on était clandestins on le faisait dans
les caves dans les maisons dont dont un
peu partout et on était poursuivi par
une voiture et à une pâle à gorki qui
nous cherchait et vous savez on n'était
pas libre la liberté d'expression et
faire connaître les différentes cultures
représentent les deux lignes
conductrices de la radio depuis 42 ans
l'esprit de la radio libre ça c'est très
très très important la radio libre c'est
quoi pour nous c'est le droit de parole
donner à tout à tout le monde à toutes
les communautés à toutes les
associations et faire connaître aussi
les différentes cultures destinations
soleil bonjour bonjour à toutes et à
tous et bienvenue sur votre fréquence 96
points de fmr vs point fr pour ceux qui
nous écoutent depuis loin dans le dans
les îles et puis dans de dangereux dans
le monde et au fil des ans la radio a su
développer une proximité avec ses
auditeurs
quand je fais les missions et holosko
pire régulièrement une auditrice qui
m'appelle je vous écoute je vous écoute
où j'ai pas eu le temps d'entendre le
début mais je suis là je suis là je vous
écoute c'est bien bravo on fait la radio
pas pour se faire plaisir mais pour
faire plaisir aux auditeurs c'est ça qui
est très important composée d'une
trentaine de bénévoles et d'une salariée
la radio du vexin et du val de seine a
encore de belles années devant elle
je vous le disais juste avant les radios
libres fêtent leurs 40 bougies cette
année l'année 1981 marque et la
libéralisation des ondes avec nous ce
soir pour continuer sur le sujet et
thierry barbeau d'heure vous êtes le
président de la radio vieille église
lille et présidente plus de culte
premiers mètres
merci d'être avec nous ce soir mais je
fais ce qu'on appelle partie du canal
historique
je vais développer un petit peu au tout
début des revues russia animer une
émission de jazz et c'est vrai dans les
années 80 le djia c'était un petit peu
élitiste et c'est vrai qu'un vieux m'a
dit pas oui pourquoi pas une petite
émission de jazz pendant une heure donc
voilà comment j'ai connu hervé comment
j'ai débuté avec harvey avait commencé à
passer avant tout cas merci d'être avec
nous et donc elle a été créée au début
des années 80 et à les situer donc à
vieille église en yvelines elle fait
partie des plus anciennes radios
yvelinoise est ce que vous nous parler
un peu de ses débuts justement aller
début c'était un petit peu compliqué
c'était un petit peu de la bidouille en
plus on est une radio qui émet 24 heures
sur 24 donc fallait qu'on trouve des
solutions pour pouvoir fonctionner 24
heures sur 24 car au départ on était
avec beaucoup de deux bénévoles
ce qui a un petit peu changé par la
suite et en fait on avait un matériel on
a
ce qu'on appelle des lecteurs à bandes
qui nous permettait d'avoir une
diffusion 24 heures sur 24 quand y avait
pas d'animateurs bénévoles sur place
justement vous parlez des bénévoles
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on fonctionne
encore beaucoup avec les bénévoles en
tant que radio associative alors il ya
quelques bénévoles mais nous on a trois
permanents donc avec un responsable
d'antenne et puis deux animateurs
salariés
plus les bénévoles ce qui nous permet de
toujours continuer en 24 24 bien
évidemment il ya des émissions
enregistrées puisque même de la nuit il
n'y a pas de moi ça à la radio est nommé
on aimait toujours 24/24 donc avec trois
paiements et du coup donc pour revenir
en 1981 il ya eu donc avec cette
libéralisation un explosion en fait
enfin une explosion pardon du nombre de
radios qu'est ce qui a changé
fondamentalement avec cette nouvelle loi
est est ce que vous êtes nostalgique
vous des débuts parce que vous étiez un
peu ce qu'on appelait une radio pirate
au tout début un petit peu de nostalgie
comme parce que c'est vrai dans les
années 80 c'était la grande nouveauté
on pouvait le faire réellement à la
vision de tout le monde alors qu'au
départ c'était un petit peu compliqué on
faisait ça dans son garage avec un petit
émetteur pas très puissant avec une
qualité un petit peu déplorable mais bon
c'était le fait de démarrer quelque
chose et la libéralisation ça justement
permis d' d'être bien visible et de
produire on va dire des choses on va
dire concrète
à ce moment là la belle époque c'était
la belle époque avec la belle époque
vous vous êtes donc une radio
associative est ce qu on a plus de
liberté au niveau de la diffusion quand
une radio associative à on a une
certaine liberté une certaine liberté
pardon mais on est quand même soumis au
csa donc quand même le csa contrôle ce
que l'on diffuse
c'est tout ce qui est musique chronique
enfin et c est quand même faire
attention à ce que l'on fait il faut
qu'on garde par exemple notre neutralité
par rapport on va dire sur les aspects
politiques par exemple et justement
aujourd'hui comment la radio a évolué et
comment se démarque des autres elle
évolue en fait
modifier la grille de programmation
depuis fin août on fait ce qu'on appelle
des petits formats au niveau des
chroniques on s'est aperçu qu'en fait
les gens
-cinq fin de dix minutes pardon lâché un
petit peu prise donc on a fait des
chroniques de 5 minutes à
une radio locale on a des chroniques sur
la consommation chronique sport enfin ce
genre de choses mais sur des petits
formats et depuis que l'on fait ça on
s'est aperçu que les auditeurs étaient
friands justement des petits formats
parce que ça permettait bon quelques
quelques minutes d'avoir un maximum
d'informations fausses une information
de qualité de la formation nationale
mais toujours en petit format
quand on parle du coup d'évolution a
parlé aussi peut-être un petit peu
matériel au départ on est un peu de la
bidouille aujourd'hui comment évaluer a
évolué ce matériel est ce qu'on a plus
de moyens forcément alors en moyens dont
une association donc on fonctionne avec
des subventions il faut faire attention
quand même au budget ce qui se passe est
qu'actuellement nous on a des studios
qui sont en analogique là sur 2022 on va
faire une transition vers le numérique
ce qui va permettre d'avoir une qualité
sonore bien supérieur
ce qui au niveau de l'écouté quand même
fort sympathique quand quand on nous
écoute et l'autre démarche on est en
train de voir sur l'aspect de date plus
puisque on en entend parler actuellement
et bah on plisse que de faire un
partenariat avec une entreprise locale
de rambouillet pour tout vous dire à
vous parler de deux subventions
justement aujourd'hui il ya une réalité
aussi économiques comment on fait après
40 ans enfin avec les subventions mais
après 40 ans pour maintenir une radio
associative
finalement
c'est ce que je vous disais donc ces
subventions connaît le budget que l'on a
donc on y fait très attention sachant
que du fait d'avoir trois permanents
dont trois salariés comme tout le monde
le sait quand on est une entreprise il
ya les salaires et les cotisations donc
ça représente une grosse partie du
budget que l'on a et on fait très
attention on va dire tout ce qui est
investissement
laon
on a la possibilité je prends je parlais
de la transition vers le numérique on a
la possibilité d'avoir des subventions
dès que ce qu'on appelle des subventions
d'équipement et on veut en profiter sur
l'année 2022 donc il ya tout un dossier
à monter c'est relativement complexe au
départ de monter ce type de dossier
après une fin de séance et s'est lancé
justement du coup me disiez les nouveaux
défis finalement c'est ça c'est cette
transition vers le numérique aujourd'hui
vous avez puisque le monde de
l'analogique existe toujours mais avec
ses défauts mais avec ses qualités
également et c'est vrai qu'en passant au
numérique ça permet de
d'implémenter beaucoup plus de choses
donc c'est pour ça qu'on se lance dans
ce défi l'inde sur 2022 de faire la
transition dans le numérique donc
finalement c'est à dire que cette loi de
1981 la bouleverser totalement
finalement la radio complètement et dans
une radio faut continuer à évoluer de
toute façon tu sois programmation ou
même tous soient matérielles enfin ça
c'est l'aspect que les auditeurs ne
voyais pas mais ça fait partie d'un tout
c'est fait partie d'un tout et puis
continuer à motiver les gens qui sont
justement dans la radio
sur la partie bénévoles et puis aussi
bien évidemment par rapport
permanents qui sont là leur proposer de
nouvelles idées et justement je m'appuie
sur sur les gens qui sont en permanence
au niveau de la radio selon propose
certaines choses donc on a un
responsable d'antenne qui nous dit oui
c'est bon oui c'est pas bon oui mais et
puis même et c'est un travail
collaboratif en fait sur erreur on est
c'est vraiment un travail collaboratif
que soient les bénévoles ou les
permanents on est un groupe moi j'ai je
dis souvent on est sur un même bateau
font un capitaine donc c'est moi le
capitaine mais on est tous à faire ramer
ce bateau à faire avancer ce bateau et
c'est très important et en tant que
capitaine vous avez vu donc toute
l'évolution de la radio foot à
l'évolution de la radio y manger j'ai
perdu un petit peu pendant quelques
années mais bon j'y suis revenue
rapidement
merci beaucoup et ses rives un rôdeur
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes président de hervé eux la
radio au tennis merci à vous
[Musique]
je vous le disais en titre cette semaine
c'est le retour du dossier de la
rédaction consacré à la hausse des prix
notamment depuis octobre le prix de
l'essence monte en flèche la conséquence
de nombreux automobilistes sont obligés
de trouver des solutions pour réduire la
facture l'une d'entre elles c'est le
covoiturage domicile travail le
reportage de céline agathe son go il est
16h 50 à elancourt kevin du gué
architecte système dans un groupe
aéronautique sort du travail il va
rentrer chez lui mais avant cela il doit
aller chercher sa passagère à quelques
kilomètres de là depuis deux semaines
cet automobiliste fait du covoiturage
avec la hausse des prix du carburant il
a trouvé un moyen de réduire sa facture
j'ai fait mon calcul parce que je fais
pas du covoiturage tous les jours je
devrais obtenir peu près une trentaine
d'euros dans le mois sur une semaine
l'automobiliste fait à peu près 2 à 3
trajet en covoiturage ce qui lui permet
d'être également autonome quand ils le
souhaitent ils utilisent l'application
claque site qui met en relation un
conducteur et un passager pour un
parcours domicile travail en plus je
cherchais un moyen de pouvoir faire des
économies de carburant tout en
contribuant un petit peu à
l'environnement et il m'a dit ah bah
tiens moi j'utilise une application
claque site assez régulièrement ces
pratiques t'as pas grand-chose à faire
la lutte à t'inscrire et finalement les
gens se mettent en relation assez
facilement donc j'ai essayé et xinum
quelques jours après j'ai rencontré
sophie direction bois d'arcy kevin
duguay met environ cinq minutes pour
récupérer sophie leclerc technicienne
laboratoire en contrôle qualité il ne
fait aucun détour sur son trajet
quotidien
ç'a passé une bonne journée
on conjointe à trouver un emploi donc on
avait qu'une seule voiture pour nous
deux donc je prenais la voiture jusqu'à
présent sauf que bâle a vu qu'il a
trouvé un emploi lui a besoin de la
voiture pour aller à son travail et du
coup bah moi j'ai besoin de covoiturer
ou de prendre le bus qui est plus facile
pour moi du coup ce que c'était soit ça
soit racheter une voiture ile-de-france
mobilité est en partenariat avec
l'application claque site sophie leclerc
détenant un pass navigo peut obtenir
jusqu'à deux trajets de covoiturage par
jour gratuitement quant à kevin duguay
il est rémunéré à hauteur de 1 euro 50
par trajet et par passager donc en fait
ce bien les conducteurs au début on peut
peut-être se dire ah bah tiens noro 50
finalement est ce que ça représente
grand chose eh bien on voit qu'avec la
hausse du prix du carburant il ya de
l'intérêt clac site a constaté une
hausse en octobre de plus de 50 % des
inscriptions conducteur et passagers par
rapport à septembre c'est sûr qu'octobre
fait prendre une conscience une
conscience de plus en plus forte que la
voiture finalement tout de même pour de
la courte distance eh bien ça coûte cher
des biotopes sur saint quentin en
yvelines plus de 40000 trajets sont
proposés c'est l'un des premiers réseaux
en france pour l'application claque site
les classes départ c'est un programme
d'insertion socioprofessionnelle en sept
mois destinée aux jeunes en décrochage
scolaire est en isolement social dans
les yvelines sept jeunes s'entraînent au
chant au théâtre ou encore à la danse
depuis donc plusieurs mois mardi à
mercredi donc 9 et 10 novembre et ils
présenteront leur spectacle à la ferme
de bel ébat le théâtre de guyancourt un
reportage de sénéchal
sept mois pour prendre conscience de soi
et des autres et construire un projet de
vie c'est le temps qu'a donné le
programme place départ à ces jeunes en
décrochage je faisais pas déçu que
j'avais pas de travail et je savais pas
vraiment
quoi m'orienter nez ou aller ce qui me
plaisait je savais pas vraiment essayer
de changer la vie de ces jeunes leur
donner énormément dans vie le goût ou le
goût au travail c'est pas c'est pas un
gros mot les réhabituer à ce que après
ses sept mois ils puissent effectivement
bas qu'ils aient acquis le fait
d'arriver à l'heure de tout donner quand
on est effectivement
avec une équipe pour pouvoir créer
quelque chose du travail dans une
entreprise théâtre danse chant ou encore
peinture ces jeunes vont proposer une
pièce poétique écrite à partir de leurs
propres histoires des histoires souvent
difficiles qui parlent de leurs peurs et
de leurs blessures l'objectif se libérer
et grandir du passé pour mieux
appréhender le futur en cède et à la fin
c'est comme si
comme si on avait tout laissé sur la
scène et qu'on partait libre grâce au
chant odin c'est à tout ça au théâtre
ça permet de s'extérioriser ça permet
vraiment de se découvrir soi-même à
travers l'art il y en a certains il
s'était en boule dans leur coin sans
parler à personne en arrivant quoi on ne
pouvant pas et j'ai plus que tout les
mêmes plus du tout les mêmes la pièce
sera présentée au théâtre de guyancourt
à la ferme de bel ébat les 9 et 10
novembre prochain puis à leur ai dit ça
plaisir les 24 et 25 novembre
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à tous
de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver michael et demi d'euros à la
présentation de votre magazine sportif
très bonne soirée à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]